I am the dumbest, most successful trader
that you will ever meet. While everyone
else is trying to trade like they're
performing brain surgery in a blender, I
am consistently and confidently making
regular trades that look like this,
trades that look like this, and even
trades that look like this using nothing
more than one simple strategy called the
sneaky pivot. [music]
This is the easiest and fastest way for
any trader of any skill level with any
account size to start taking steps
forward [music] because all you need to
be able to do to master this strategy is
use one time frame, one candlestick, and
give up 15 minutes of your time. And I
think for a lot of you, that's pretty
easy to do, right? Now, my name is Doug
and I've been a professional trader now
for 26 years. And one of the hardest
lessons I ever had to learn was every
time I tried to get smarter, cuter, or
more clever with the market, every time
I did that, it always made me look
stupid. And I know for a lot of you that
are watching, that's the exact same
thing that's happening [music] to you.
You're putting in the work. You're
trying as hard as you can, but your
results are getting worse. And what you
need right now is the exact same thing I
needed then. You don't need to get
smarter. You need to get simpler. And
maybe even a little dumber. So, in
today's video, I'm going to show you
exactly how to trade this sneaky pivot
strategy. But before we get into that, I
want you to know something. I am not
going to sit up here and waste your time
and just talk to you about it and show
you a bunch of hypothetical hindsight
examples because talk is cheap in this
industry. I am going to show you exactly
how this strategy works by trading it in
a live market with real money, with real
pressure, and real consequences. That
way, by the time this video's over, you
can make the decision for yourself if
you think the sneaky pivot strategy is
as simple as I say it is, or you're
going to watch me lose money trying. How
about we get started with today's video?
So, first things first, in order for you
to get the most out of today's video and
for you to get the most out of the
Sneaky Pivot strategy, we have to have
our chart set up correctly. Now, like I
mentioned there in the introduction, the
reason so many people get along with
this strategy and they love it is
because there aren't very many moving
parts, starting with the time frame.
Where other strategies have you bouncing
around back and forth between multiple
monitors looking at different time
frames, Sneaky Pivot only needs one time
frame. And the one time frame is a
15-minute. So, let's start with that and
set it up on our chart. That's pretty
easy to do. For reference, I'm going to
start today's video with the YM Dow
futures here. Doesn't matter what's up
there. Just move it over to a 15-minute
chart. Just click the 15-minute time
frame and that's all you have to do.
Notice, no indicators, no mess, no
noise. Now, once we've done that, we can
move on to the very first step. And
here's what it is. We need to identify
something called the range high and the
range low and also the swing high and
swing low. And let me show you what I'm
talking about. Starting with the range
high. The range high and low is going to
be the previous day's high and low price
of the asset you're trading. So, if you
take your eyes and you scoot them over
here to the left, you're going to see
that this black shaded area represents
the previous day's trading activity in
the YM futures. So, what we're looking
for here is the highest price point we
see printed and we're looking for the
lowest price point that we see printed.
These represent the range high and low.
So, what I'm going to do is grab some
sort of horizontal line, some trend line
that your software has. I'm going to
come over here and lay the line on top
of the highest price I see. Just get as
close as you can with your eyes and the
lowest price I see from the previous
day. And this high and low represents
the range high and low. Now, the next
step with this, the swing high and swing
low. In layman's terms, the swing high
and swing low in this case is the next
level up above the range high and the
next level below the range low. Now, if
you look at the chart I have here on the
screen, you don't see that price on the
left. So, what you need to do in this
case is minimize your chart and go back
to the left as far as you can until you
find the next price that was higher than
the range high. So, range high, we move
back to the left and right there is that
next swing high. That will make our
swing high. So, let's go ahead.
We'll lay a line right on top of that.
And we're going to do the same thing
below. We're going to go back and we're
going to look for the next low that we
see, which is right here, okay? That
should be pretty easy for everyone.
Let's go ahead and put a line on that.
And those upper lines and lower lines
represent the swing high, swing low,
range high, range low. Very simple. Now,
these might be recognizable to a lot of
people watching because these are the
rumors magic lines. Now, let me show you
a trick here. If you happen to be using
the TradingView software, you can
actually come up into your indicator
menu here, hit the drop-down tab and
search for the rumors magic lines, and
click them, and they'll put them on
there for you. And better than that,
it'll actually layer another one up and
another one below. But just to make this
video simple, and not everyone's using
the TradingView software, we're going to
stick with the lines that we have to
keep everything clean, but I thought I'd
mention it for those that use
TradingView. Now, that's all we need to
do to establish the range high, the
range low, the swing high, and the swing
low. Now, onto the good stuff. Once
we've drawn these lines, what do they
mean, and how are we going to trade
them? And I'll show you. Let's say, for
example, this is your swing high, this
is your range high. This is your range
low. And this is your swing low. First,
most important, yet very easy rule. We
are only, I mean only going to buy
or sell the asset we're trading if and
only if it is at one of those lines. So,
in the beginning I told you it was
simple. There was few moving parts. We
have one time frame,
one chart, and four lines. You only buy
and sell at those lines. Simple.
Anywhere else, leave it alone. So, now
the question is, which are the buy lines
and which are the sell lines? And here
they are. The upper two lines are the
sell side lines. What these are are the
upper bands of resistance of the asset
you're trading. And in layman's terms,
what this means is this is the strongest
sell side force. And every time the
asset you're trading has moved into that
level, it has been met with nothing but
sellers. And until those sellers leave
that asset, it will never go any higher.
It will stay there. In inverse
relationship, the bottom two lines are
the strongest buy side force. This is
where the market's muscle memory is
programmed to buy. Every time the asset
pulls into one of those levels, it gets
bought. This is what we want to do. We
want to sell at the upper two lines. We
want to buy at the lower two lines. Now,
here's something that happens every day
where the edge of the strategy gets
enhanced. Now, some of you might know
this or have experienced it, but here's
exactly what happens in most cases every
day that you trade. Regardless of what
you trade, what normally happens is for
the first 15 minutes of each day,
the asset you're trading ping-pongs or
kind of moves back and forth between the
range high and range low, trying to test
both the sell side force and the
buy-side force. Now, shortly after the
15 minutes, which is important to you
and I, let's say a phenomenon happens.
What will usually take place is either
the range low gets broken and it
immediately visits the swing low or the
range high gets broken and it visits the
swing high almost every single time.
Now, here is what you and I are looking
to do and what the sneaky pivot takes
advantage of. We are looking to either
sell into the range high and trade it
back into the swing low or we are
looking to buy at the swing low or the
range low and trade it back to either
the swing high or the range high. Now,
let me show you exactly the candlestick
formation we are going to do and how
this execution works. So, because the
sneaky pivot is a very simple strategy,
it uses a three candlestick framework.
And the candlestick framework looks like
this. We're looking for a strong, bold
opening 15-minute candle. We're going to
call this the opening range candle.
It'll look something like this. Next is
more important. The following 15-minute
candle is something we call the sneaky,
hence the sneaky pivot. The sneaky
candle serves two things. It lets us
know the legitimacy of the first candle,
like what actually happened there. More
importantly, it's going to tell us what
the third 15-minute candle means. This
third 15-minute candle, which in most
cases is going to happen at the
45-minute mark of each day, that right
there, for all intents and purposes, is
going to be our entry. Now, the
three-step framework itself is pretty
simple, but what's the most important
part of this framework is not just those
candles, but how they look and more
importantly where they appear, hence why
we started the video talking about the
magic line levels. So, let's go back to
the YM chart and let me show you exactly
how you're going to dial down this
entry. Okay, so back to the YM chart we
started with. I left the lines up and
just for a quick refresher, the upper
lines is the range high, the swing high,
the lower lines range low, swing low.
What is the rules, my friends? We only
sell up here, we only buy down here. And
what do we do? What do we do in all of
this mess? We just stare at the chart.
We twiddle our thumbs. We maybe check
our Facebook or Instagram, but we don't
do anything with the instrument we are
trading. So, what we're going to do is
wait for that first 15-minute bar and it
will tell us what level it picks. We
don't have to choose being bullish or
bearish. We're going to let the first 15
minutes tell us what it is we need to
do. Now, this is a playback here before
we get into the live trading just so you
understand exactly how this works. So,
when you see it live, you're already
where you need to be with it, but I'm
going to play the first bar through and
what you're going to see happens is it
immediately plows all the way to the
lower part of the range, which is the
swing low, okay? So,
let me ask you a question. What would
you do in this situation? Someone is
forcing you to push this button right
here on the mouse.
Are you a buyer or are you a seller?
You're obviously a buyer. But here's the
thing we have to understand. We can't
just randomly buy that because maybe
today's the day the entire thing
implodes. We're all out on the street
corner eating soup cans, carrying
backpacks, heading for the hills. We
need what? The sneaky candle. So, maybe
it's the next candle, maybe it's the
following candle, but we need the sneaky
candle. So, the very next candle that
prints in this sequence, you're going to
see is a green one. Now at this point we
have the confirmation that we need and
this is what I want to show you. First
and foremost is this lower swing low.
Now one of the things newer traders tend
to mess up with and I did too was I used
to think technical analysis was literal.
Like I would draw that line and say,
"That's my stop. That's where I'm in.
That's where I'm out." But really it's
just a range. So note the first candle
came, it printed all the way at the low
slightly below the swing low and then
the next candle is green. So this is
that sneaky candle which means the
market is intending on being bought back
up. But again, this might be a sucker
candle. Maybe the next one just
implodes, but we have that stability.
Now mind you, these are 15-minute
candles. So this is 30 continual minutes
where the lows have been tapped over and
over again. So if you were to pull up
something like a 1-minute chart or a
5-minute chart, there would be a bunch
of taps and wicks on that low, but it's
a lot cleaner cuz it's a 15-minute. So
what we're going to do is look to buy
above that candle. So the very next one
pops up through here and you'll see it
goes right above that. Now here's where
the entry comes in which is the same for
the pattern scalp, the same for the
opening range reversal, the same I use
in this three-step strategy is we always
need one candle to go over another
candle and here's what I mean by it.
When the price crossed that 15-minute
candle, which was 49 521,
that is the entry. The moment it pushes
above the candle, that's the entry. So
in this case, we would buy it. Now
remember, this is a little bit late on
the entry, but what we're going to do is
place that stop loss right underneath
the big buyer. Now, I've mentioned this
so many times in my last videos. This is
what I want new people to understand.
This is what I want struggling traders
to understand. This is what I want
anybody to understand who isn't making
money trading. You're always getting
stopped out because you never did these
levels in the first place. That's why we
started the video with the levels,
right? If our stop loss is under the big
buyer or above the big seller, I've said
before it's like our guardian angel.
It's a protection device. We're most
likely not going to get stopped out
because this buyer has been tested for a
half an hour and it's continually
bought. So, that's a pretty simple
standard format, right? Everybody agrees
with that. We got the entry, right? So,
now it comes the target cuz every trader
struggles with these targets. Am I
correct? They all struggle with I
struggle with targets. You're struggling
with targets. Here's how we fix it.
Because the sneaky pivot is a
range-bound strategy, and the reason we
drew those lines in the first place is
because that's where it's going back to.
That's where it's going back to in most
cases, and that's what we want our
target price to be. Either the top of
the candle or somewhere back against the
bigger seller. Let's just go back with
the biggest seller here, and you'll see
that even a couple of more times like
some of these times it takes a while to
get up there. But, here's what I want to
do. Let me stop that. That's moving a
little too fast.
>> [snorts]
>> Here's something that you have to keep
in mind, and this I'm glad I actually
used this example. I didn't even know it
here. But, here's what I want to show
you.
Note that
the ending part of this will eventually
come. And this is again a big struggle
for traders. Patience, okay? Note that,
you know, about a What is that? 45
minutes?
It just kind of stayed there, and it
kept dropping and popping, dropping.
Look at these wicks. Look how many times
that buyer was tested. Now, in most
cases this is going to come off of the
third or fourth bar.
But the point is sometimes it doesn't.
And this is what every trader who's
watching this needs to understand. The
drawings from the textbook, the drawings
from the candlestick chart, they don't
look like that in real world
environment. What I want you to focus on
is trust. Trusting the lower ranged by
I'm going to move this one down right
here where the stop would be. As long as
that thing is holding the low, your
trade's still valid. It may suck to be
in it. It may suck that it hasn't
rallied, but you need to stay in that,
okay? That's exactly the kind of trade
we are looking for is to take it from
the base of either the range low to
swing low back to the range high to the
swing high. Now, this is a very simple
strategy. All of you should have the
three-stick framework. You should
understand the lines. So, there's no
reason for us to do anything else
but start live trading. I told you I was
going to put myself on the line. Now's
the time to do it. Let's trade this in a
real market, and you can decide for
yourself. Okay, so the first trade has
been made for today.
We have a long here in AAOI,
and it is five Yeah, 500 shares,
$170.32.
Now, I left these magic lines up here,
and this is with thinkorswim, so it's
kind of a little bit messy in terms of
view. I want to show you this in in
TradingView because there's a slight
change here
to these magic lines. I want to show you
something that's pretty interesting
here, but right now it's
500 shares,
$172.32.
I think most people can see this, but
let me kind of move this
TradingView over here real quick. This
is the last bar that printed here, and I
just kind of want to
go through this because there is a
change to these magic lines, and let me
talk about it here and my attention
might get moved back and forth. So,
first thing
is we're looking for range high, range
low, swing high, swing low, right? So,
the previous day's high and low price
are right in here, okay?
Which makes the swing high
the very next high above that, right
here, the 184.
And then of course the swing low isn't
isn't too much further. It's right
underneath of that. So, just like the
rest of them, there's this huge gap in
between and usually the swing high,
range high, swing low and range low are
pretty compressed like that. Now, if you
take a look at this
AAOI, it didn't quite make it there, but
it was close enough for me and I'll I'll
tell you why.
First of all, this is about a
$15 candlestick. That's that's pretty
aggressive, right?
And it's very rangy. So, a lot of times
they don't give you that opportunity,
but I want to open this up because there
is a little bit of an adjustment here
you can make. This was the third candle
entry was around that 170.32.
So, if I lay my cursor right there,
that's about 170.35.
So, that was right on point with the
entry just kind of cresting the sneaky
candle here, right? But note that what I
want everybody to understand is this.
Note the three wicks at the bottom,
which was in this area. Sorry for
messing up this chart. I'm going to keep
my eye on this straight.
area. So, like down in here, you've got
those three three points where the lower
buyer has been tested. So, that's I mean
that's pretty good right there. There's
not much you can do and you can see this
wick kind of just turned around. It
looked like it was just going to pop
back through the low. Let me open that
up where it's nice and I it. Just right
there. I mean, it looked like it was
going to dive right in there to the low.
Snaps back up. There's the entry.
Now, this is really, really far. I mean,
really far between the next time. So,
there's a good chance you can still make
it back to 182. You can always reduce
the magic lines to the opening candle
like the high
and the low of the 15-minute candle. If
it's really, really aggressive like that
and it's range extended where it's
chewed up most of the daily range.
You can always wait for that first
15-minute candle to close, mark the high
and low, and start working off of there
and you'll see
that's kind of what it is. So, I just
wanted to show it there cuz there was a
few differences in the
magic lines, but the the the end result
is the same. You got close enough to the
bottom range.
And of course, what we're trying to do
is trade you back up in here to the top
part of this range. That's a long way to
go. That'd be a hell of a good trade,
but that's what we're going to try to
do. Okay?
So, I will keep you updated on this one.
Okay, back on the mic real quick. We got
another one. We have long GGL. This is a
Google ETF.
Uh price is 1,000 shares
13664.
And I'm going to explain this one here
on TradingView because it is easier to
do that. Let me queue that up here real
quick.
Just give me a second. Okay. So, here's
what it looks like. This is GGLL. This
is a Google
ETF. Um
the bar's already been trading. So,
because this is a replay, the bar hasn't
finished. We jumped in pretty early and
it kind of took off. I I think most of
you at this point can can follow along
with this process, right? I want to do
just, you know, one more overview of of
the magic lines and the trade and all
that good stuff. So, going back to the
previous day's high price and low price
cuz I think on both of these,
they're a little different um because
everything is so rangy. The bottom's
pretty easy. It actually was a double
bottom there on the daily chart. And
again, coming up just a tad bit short.
So, this would be range high, range low.
And then you have to go back really,
really far here. Actually, no, not too
much.
That'd be the swing high.
And then the swing low would be way down
here. Again, another rangy
instrument because this is an ETF that
mirrors the stock Google. But you're
seeing the same pattern.
Is that
the middle range is always so wide.
So, just like AAOI, you you didn't quite
make it down there, but you had the same
same thing. Three tail wicks
close to the big buyer. And you're just
looking for that cross. And I want to
show you these because
you know, in real life terms like this,
technical analysis this is not literal.
That's close enough.
And it was just it's always just the
same trade as AOI. Um Now, you can
always, again, just use the opening
15-minute candle, but I think this is
this is fine. There should be at least a
uh an outside chance it makes a a push
up towards the upper seller before the
day's over. Uh but I mean, that's it.
Straightforward, pretty simple stuff.
Right?
>> [snorts]
>> All right. So, it's been a little while,
but looking at GGLL. What a monster.
Went right back up to that open range
there.
Uh
good trade so far. 14 on this one.
Uh so, we're going to target that next
area up there, 1
39.54.
And if we could go back over here real
quick. Where is it? There it is. AAOI.
This one's working slacken lagging a
little bit there. But I think if we get
through that 176, we can get that upper
range. I mean, look at that. Um
let's hope that candle sticks.
Yeah, about 18 on this one, so
we got there almost 3K on these two.
Looking good. I mean, at this point,
it's just
it's just auto pilot. I mean, hopefully
you guys can can see it here.
It's just it's simple. I mean, as simple
as simple can get, right?
>> [sighs]
>> Okay, it's been a long day. I'm tired,
but I'm going to update you on these
trades. And I really want to do this one
because when you trade live, you get
live situations. Remember, no
cherry-picked charts or circumstances.
We had a little change. We had one turn
out real good out of those trades, and
one
one kind of stuck it to us, man. It
sucked a little bit. So, let's start
with the good one here. AAOI Um take a
look at this. Later in the day, it had
moved up quite a bit. It was lagging
Google GLL there for a minute. Taps the
top range, and look where it ends up.
Gets right up there, right at the end of
the day. Now, the market's closed now,
but right there towards the
end of the day, it taps into that that
upper
seller. Perfect. So, we got a lot more
out of this one, almost almost 3K. So,
that that's pretty good.
But, Google
Google was very, very mean to us. Let me
pull this up here, GLL. Oh my my. Take a
look what happened here.
>> [sighs]
>> Google got stuffed. I mean, everything
looked really good uh making a really
nice V shape.
Uh
but damn, it got rejected. I had to turn
around and cut this
as it started dropping. I mean, just
kind of it felt like out of nowhere. The
first this 15-minute bar just plowed. It
was so fast and it dropped so quick.
I held onto it through here cuz I
thought maybe it would, you know, kind
of flag and revisit like it did back
here. But, damn, the thing went down. I
mean, all the way into the
the big buy. I mean, if there was more
time in the market, I would probably buy
that. But, you know, it shows you they
just kind of tap range to range. Really
disappointing cuz I think at one time
the height of this was almost 2K.
And, um as you can see, they sold it for
um
rublets. Let's say rublets. I mean, they
gave a chunk back on this, but the ROI
was
uh was good, right? So, anyway,
uh real stuff there. So,
again, guys, I think the the process is
really simple at this point. You see the
trades. That's two for two.
Well, the Google was kind of upsetting,
but, you know,
that happens from time to time when you
trade, and it's just what you have to do
with if you're going to participate in
this.
So, anyway, I'm going to wrap up this
video.
It's been a long day. I hope you learned
something. If you're looking for a great
selection of ideas down in the
description box, we send a free watch
list out every week. Sent on Sunday.
It's completely free. Something we offer
to the community. The link is down in
the description. And as always, I want
to thank you for watching today's video.
It's my pleasure. Take care, trade well.
Until the next video.
Cheers.